You did your PhD here.
>> Yes.
>> And,
I had the privilege of working with you.
And, there are certain areas that
you are very passionate about in
cyber security.
I remember you sent me your book,
What Google Knows About Us.
Is that interest still to
occupy some of your time?
>> So, I'm focused really
on four varying areas.
Usable security,
which I think is of critical importance.
Security data visualization, the idea
of being able to present information to
humans, to find insights
that machines can't.
Online privacy, critically,
critically important.
And, where I'm spending a lot of
time today, is cyber conflict.
Typically, what we learn in the
classroom is more system-level security.
An individual system protecting
an operating system,
or protecting a specific device.
But, we need to think bigger,
and scale up.
How do you protect a city from attack.
That's where we're putting
a lot of though into it now.